some nights I stay away capture it in my
bed look so nice I call leader I draw
some nights I wish that my lips could
build a castle most nights I don't know
anymore I love Los Angeles it's I mean I
miss my seasons and I miss my weather a
little bit but uh you know beautiful
sunny day outside so I can't complain I
like it out here
alright so now I want to get into you
know start getting into YouTube you know
you collaborate a lot with credo
Schneider and so it's a well-known fact
that you know you grew up a street away
from them how do you personally see that
for you is that coincidence fade is it
something else honestly if you had told
me when Kurt was like that kid down the
street if you had told me that in
however many years I would be in Los
Angeles making music with him a lot and
then both of us working on this music
and entertainment career I probably
would have thought you were crazy it
sort of just happens of its own accord
you know we were friends in high school
we both did the musical is in choir and
all that stuff so we knew that we both
liked music but it was in college that
we just sort of started working together
by some chance of fate and luck and you
know all the fans we built something and
and yet it's sort of gone from there but
I I had no idea when we were just kids
and you know the suburbs of Philadelphia
but we would be here today how do you
see doing covers how much artistry do
you think there is in covering other
people's songs as opposed to you know
writing your own songs and performing
those songs yeah I mean I think those
are you know two different slices of the
same high you know no matter what way
you're making music
you're still there's creating something
new even if you're reducing material
from someone else and for me it's been
incredible to to do so much cover
material because I've learned so much as
a songwriter and
musician because you know especially
when you get to take songs from vastly
different genres and and make them your
own you're not only discovering what
makes a good song and really learning
what makes these hit songs tick but
you're also by tapping to translate them
into your own voice and into your own
style it's actually a great way to
figure out what your style is and figure
out who you are by using this material
so that you know when you want to start
writing your own material I think
there's just a lot that you can learn
from from covering music and and I think
in today's world of pop music where
there's a lot of there's a lot of dance
and there's a lot of sort of repetitive
simple music and I don't mean that in a
bad way
but they're the sort of current musical
aesthetic is you know it's similar to
some extent and so it's actually it's
great music to cover because it's a
oftentimes it's a very blank canvas that
you can sort of play with in a lot of
ways and make it really fun and
different which is what I would love to
do so
yeah covering music is great obviously
original music is great as well but um I
think there's there's definitely huge
value to both what do you think makes a
really good cover standout I mean I
think the covers that I like to watch in
there for the ones that I strive to make
are our covers that that don't feel like
covers that when you're watching them
you're not even if you know the original
song you're not thinking oh this is a
this is a very cover or that you know
that that sort of transform themselves
enough so that it feels right in
whoever's voice is singing it so so yeah
whenever I go to approach a cover I
really think you know not how can I make
this song cool but the first step is how
would I sing the song what does this
song mean to me and how can I make it
into a new piece of art you know that
that uses this material and then
transforms into something new so that's
I think what makes a good cover and so
how do you go about choosing which song
do you want to cover and what you don't
I love pop music I love to listen to
radios and so
that's always a good place to start and
you know certainly when when I was
beginning of her doing popular covers
was a great way to get seen in the first
place you know because at the beginning
knowing knew who I was or incur buzz and
so you know if we picked a really
popular Beyonce saw or Lady Gaga song
you know we knew that that's how people
would start to to learn who we are
because they would be searching for that
song and then they would find us and
then they would become fans of our music
so so yeah nowadays it's it's really a
combination of you know what I'm hearing
on the radio but but also just you know
when listening to the radio what songs I
like or what songs I hear a cool version
of that we could do or that would be
conducive to a cover for us so yeah it
definitely varies but we always pick
music that would be like that that's the
most important thing if we don't like
the song it's not gonna be a big cover
so I have to make sure that it's
something that speaks to me so I noticed
with your YouTube channel it's only
about a year old but you really been at
this more than more than a year so why
did it take so long for you to start a
YouTube channel well so I've been
working with Kirk for a couple years now
and when we started that channel was
pretty much you know it's slowly the two
of us working together and then when we
both got out here we you know are both
thinking of ways to expand what we do
and work with more people and so when
and when I moved out there year ago I
thought that in addition to continuing
to work with Kurt on Kurt's channel you
know I thought it would be cool to start
my own so that not only could I be
making more content but I could you know
start working with other people as well
and really grow in that way so so yeah
while I've been working on YouTube for a
while now my personal channel the sam
tsui is only about a year old but
there's already a lot of stuff on it and
i've been amazed at how quickly it's
grown there's you know you broke it
really broke up a game when you did the
Michael Jackson ethic yes and I know so
a couple years ago you were on Oprah
yeah for it and so I really want to know
the dirty laundry on Oprah she she
attire and backstage you know what she's
she was incredibly kind to us I don't
know you know I'm she
I mean she's probably one of the
toughest jobs in the world she's running
around all the place so it's a she was
definitely a busy woman but she was
totally great to us I actually got this
is a place where I got a lot of free
shirts out of that experience so the
Michael Jackson medley which we perform
in the Oprah show that is one of the
videos where there's sort of multiple
clones of me all doing this acapella
backup and so they obviously wanted to
reproduce that effect on the show so you
know we recorded a bunch of different
versions of me singing and they had told
me to bring a bunch of wardrobe because
obviously I needed several different
outfits and I brought them and the
stylist there was like oh no we don't
like these I don't like my clothes I
don't know I feel like we you know we
want we want to get your your wardrobe
so they're like what size of small or
whatever and they went out to American
Apparel and bought literally every
single color of t-shirt and every single
color of like cardigan and so so that
they could go and then just decide so
literally there was like 30 shirts
sitting there and they're like okay we
want that one that one that one in that
one and then when we were done and when
we'd filmed it all they were like oh do
you just want to keep these shirts and
I'm like yes I do
so that clothes me for like I call them
like Oprah shirts now every time I wear
a little girl I know for sure not you
I'm sure being a well-known thinking you
know there's a lot of things about you
out there on the on the internet some
things choose something that you a lot
of speculation do you think being a
woman figure you know woody what level
of privacy do you think you know should
be afforded it's a very interesting
question and especially in this day and
age where social media plays such a big
part in in an online presence and in
building a fan base online and and yeah
and especially someone like me who is
primarily you know that's far and online
figure you know there is this sense of
accessibility that I really like that
you know someone likes my music they
have a direct line to me on my channel
and through my Twitter and things like
that and and yet you know that sort of
sense of transparency is it's it's a
tricky area you know because at the same
time you know Mike my Twitter and my
facebook and all I think that that
represents me you know and so you know
giving people access to that it's just
it's it's always a tricky a tricky
subject because you know I want to
maintain some sense of you know my
actual friends and who I know in my
daily life and yet I also do love
sharing Who I am with everyone around
the world so it's just it's it's a new
challenge and I think all people who are
in the public eye online today sort of
have to face does it differ get
uncomfortable for you when you're out
and people recognize you is it ever
coming to that plane you know I love it
that's one of the coolest coolest things
that can happen because what I'm
performing it's you know all online so
I'm filming it in front of a camera
posting it online and then and then it
sort of sent off into the ether and and
people are watching in our performance
but I don't get to be there for that
unless I'm doing a live show or
something so whenever I'm in someone on
the street who recognize me from my work
it's it's incredible because it reminds
me that
yeah when these numbers are going up on
the hits and all the stuff that actually
are real people who are appreciating
what I'm doing and who I'm making happy
through my music so I if anyone ever
sees me on the street I will take a
million pictures I'll sign whatever
because it means that that I'm
accomplishing my goal of making people
happy to my music go back to YouTube you
know your collaborator purchased matter
he recently signed with alloyed digital
and so have you sang with anybody yeah
well so as I told you my channel was
started about a year ago and so for the
first year it's really been about
growing it and it was actually kind of
cool to you know having been a part of
the Carillo the tiger channel which
obviously took off and is huge so I got
to sort of experience that growth and
then to get to sort of start again and
start a new channel and see how the
fabric of YouTube and up digital music
this change has actually been really
interesting so I've been growing that
channel and and yes it's gotten to the
point where it's become you know
something in its own right and I'm
really excited about that and so I did I
signed with with fullscreen it was great
to have sort of a network of people and
a family there to support me and it was
a great fit so I'm really excited about
that what do you think that advantages
or disadvantages are of signing with the
YouTube network well yeah obviously you
know doing content on YouTube it's it
can be very sort of isolated you know
you're you're doing especially when when
Kurt and I were doing videos at school
it was really just sort of the two of us
and we were obviously building this
global network of fans but you know the
actual production side of it was was
pretty small-scale and so the great part
about a network of some kind is that it
it opens you up to a community of people
who are all doing what you're doing and
can connect you all and you can share
resources and learn from each other as
sort of to just have that support and be
part of a family of people who are doing
the same things as you is I think really
valuable as a content creator and as a
youtuber can you tell me about your
upcoming solo absolutely this is
something I'm so excited about and in
some ways I feel like I've been building
toward this whole time yeah a lot of
youtubers have you know sort of released
original material intermittently
with their covers but for me I really
wanted to have a debut album that was
something very distinct and something
that sort of was an event and so I have
been writing songs over the past you
know three years and have really held
off on releasing them because I wanted I
wanted there to be a debut album that
people could get their hands on and say
this is this is who Sam Julia this is
his first album so I'm really excited
that I'm finally ready to to actually
put it out there and yeah it's gonna be
a full 12 to 14 track original album
it's all produced by Kurt Schneider so
it's gonna be really good and you know
company with some awesome music videos
that you know people love our videos so
I'm incredibly excited and I think it
will begin a new phase of what what I've
been doing because I he'll obviously
continue to do cover stuff and medley
stuff but I'm excited to show Who I am
as a as a musical artist and as a
songwriter what have you written about
some of your songs what have they been
about well I come from a musical theatre
background so I think that storytelling
and situation is so important in in
songwriting Anna and I don't get me
wrong I love today's pop music and I
love dance music but that's something
that I think is lacking in a lot of a
lot of the biggest artists is this sense
of specificity and story so III
definitely write about real situations
to me but I read about them in a way
that is accessible and really tells a
story melodically can you tell me about
the series of concert tours you're
having with Kurt yeah well as I said one
of the things about YouTube is that you
know we always film our videos
beforehand and then put them up and then
and then you know that video is online
and for perpetuity but it lacks this
sense of you know live performance that
is so awesome and then one of my
favorite parts about music is the live
concert music experience and so one of
the things that I'm gonna be doing with
Kurt is this hopefully series we're
doing the first one and
17 but hopefully it'll be a series of
live streaming concerts so there will be
on YouTube and they will sort of look
like a youtube video and then we're you
know doing them in a studio and you know
good cameras this up so it'll look like
the quality that fans were used to
seeing in one of our videos it's not
just like a webcam setup it'll look nice
but it will be completely live so you
know fans will get to comment in real
time we'll you know respond and have
little chats in between songs and it's
gonna be really exciting and it's not
just us we have other artists like Megan
Nicole and max Schneider and some other
big YouTube names that are kind of you
know join us so hopefully it'll be a
really cool event and ideally the first
of many because I think there's there
will be something really exciting about
watching a video on YouTube in the
YouTube screen but knowing that it's
happening completely live I think that
will bring a new level of excitement to
the YouTube viewing experience can you
tell me about the next video that you're
doing because we're working on this
album we definitely want to ramp up our
video productions and make sure that for
the next couple months in addition to
working on this album we're still
bringing people lots of content so there
will be a lot of videos in the in the
coming weeks and months the next one I'm
really excited about it's a duet with
the incredibly talented Megan Nicole we
just recorded it last night actually and
we're going to do a video this weekend
it's a mash-up that should be really
cool really fun so I'm excited about
that hey it's Jeff glamo for new media
rockstars and you guys definitely got a
pop back check out going on with next
week
okay